the suspension on the debt ceiling
it's over the debt ceiling has not been
raised and
the u.s is now essentially liquidating
assets to pay its debts
which is scary but hopefully they'll
raise the debt ceiling because it seems
kind of dumb not to anyway they just do
it and keep taking in more and more debt
but at the same time
the eviction moratorium has ended it
seems like things are kind of breaking
and falling apart because now we're
hearing there's got to be more
more restrictions more masks all of this
weird authority authoritarian stuff is
happening
meanwhile in chicago they're saying hey
everybody you gotta wear masks we gotta
get this thing under control
and then they have lollapalooza with
thousands of people not wearing masks
all partying
they say the vaccine is here it's it's
it's got excellent efficacy
and yet still they're saying we need to
lock everything down it just
seems like creeping authoritarianism on
top of all that
critical race theory and critical race
applied principles
the wokeness seeping into our government
into our culture into our politics
it's uh i guess you put these things
together and it sounds like really bad
things are happening
obviously and our economy is in trouble
our government is in trouble and our
culture is in trouble
and now we're being joined by an actual
survivor of mao's cultural revolution
who says
that there is a cultural revolution
happening here in the us and it is
critical race theory we are joined by
lily tong williams
do you want to introduce yourself oh hi
tim thanks for having me nice to meet
you because i've been watching
you guys for a while yes i actually was
born in chengdu sutran province of prc
two years before mouse cultural
revolution two years so i did not only
say i was a child
um so from 1966 to 1976
mao mouse used the cultural revolution
to really purge his political enemies
inside of a communist party um
do you know about the grape lead forward
from 1958 to 1961
mao basically his policies
and made the estimated
20 meaning to 40 meaning chinese
died of mass famine we were told
of course later i was too young that i'm
not born yet
but when i was growing up they said that
was three years natural disasters
wow that night i did not know anything
about it until i come to this country
i discovered the truth but today in
maine and china
1.4 billion people i bet
there are still majority people don't
know the truth if they know they might
not be so
you know like a quiet and passive would
just let them continue to rule over them
and so so so so mao basically they lost
some power we got the new
called the president nusa chi and he saw
him
as a threat with his supporters so mao
went outside of beijing and used the
what you called life college
students idealistic who worship him
to start cultural revolution to say
we're going to get rid of four
oats what is a four oats you can even
make their collection today it's called
old culture old custom
old ideas and old habits
let's use cultural revolution get rid of
all those
so change names and change
last names of your family members to cut
ties
so all that stuff we can get into yeah
you know a lot of it's like 1984 it said
the the statues were taken down
the names of streets were changed
everything that was old was purged
we'll talk about all of that we'll talk
about your story we're also hanging out
with ian
very excited that you're here lily thank
you for coming my pleasure ying
and i am also excited to be here and
listen to your stories because i think
this is exceedingly important for this
time in uh
american history unfortunately and
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member and you'll
get access to exclusive members only
segments from this show they go around
11 p.m monday through thursday
and you'll get an advertisement free
experience on all of our news articles
as well as just generally supporting the
work
we're doing as we're expanding we just
had a meeting about one of our other
shows we just had people flat for
another show we're doing totally
cultural shows by the way
because we want to inspire people have a
good time and not always just be talking
about politics and getting people down
we want to
inspire people to do things that can
actually help bring about positive
change
talking about it complaining about it
isn't enough what do we have as an
alternative
what will make people feel good and say
you know what that authoritarianism i
don't want that stuff
i want to have a good time with my
friends so we're focusing on that go to
timcast.com become a member don't forget
to like this video
share the show with your friends if you
really like the show today is going to
be very conversational because
this is a warning to everybody you know
we we've said in the show many times
that
critical race theory critical race
applied principles
leftist identitarianism whatever the
word is
we can see what's happening and they use
different ways to manipulate they'll say
oh it's not critical race theory oh
wokeness doesn't mean anything oh that's
a
pejorative oh social justice they change
the word every time
that's why i say wokeness or leftist
identitarianism
whatever you want to call it we'll call
it the left's cultural revolution
we have somebody who actually
experienced it who knows a bit about
what happens
if you don't resist it and someone who
is saying it's
happening here which should be a warning
to everybody that should be uh
more than scary i suppose but uh you
know keep calm and carry on and we'll
learn about what's happening so let's
just let's just jump in and get started
do you want to tell us uh first let's
let's start here in america
you said that what's happening here with
critical race theory
and i think it's it's important to
mention it's well beyond critical race
theory
but this these these changes we're
seeing from the left this is a culture
revolution in
in america well as somebody who survived
mouse culture revolution it's very
terrifying to say lots of similarities
um the similarities that people who
don't know about mouse cultural
revolution he used
karl marx theory communist manifesto
author
to separate people into primarily two
big groups well heard those names
oppressor
versus oppressed and who are under
oppressors group in mouth china
rich farmers landlord
rightists bad influencers and
country revolutionaries south family
bad influencers yeah who are those
people and rightists
yes that's like basically anybody they
could just be like you're a bad
influencer
anybody who is not in eye with a
mouse party which is a one party rule in
china today
ccp china's communist party
and anybody who disagrees with the party
policies
or trying to offer some suggestions to
say we can
improve china better maybe by doing
better
economically you all can be classified
as the
so-called black classes five classes
they're under oppressed i was one of
supposed to be oppressed
called workers peasants
communist party members officials
people's liberation armies
because comedies when's all about
polo terrance rule workers unite right
have you heard that before marxist terms
all you could call that equity equity
today
do people even know that's a company's
term equity
equal outcomes by forcefully doing
wealth redistribution that's what the
mall did
he promised we're going to have you know
land
taking from the rich give to the
peasants we're going to take
over all the private properties like
factories
industries so we can
give to the people equally people
always buy into that kind of promise
that never came
you know never can and how many people
did he kill to to enact that vision
under mao 20 to 40 million people
storming to death during the great leap
forward
campaign he did from 1958 to 1961
then during his 10 years cultural
revolution
from 1966 to 1976
20 million people died add those lumber
together
our kids have no idea when i tell them
do you know more people
died under mouse communist china
then hitler no did not know that
too bad we don't teach emphasize
the horrors of communism
especially on their mouth i went to
venezuela once
and i went to a protest the people who
were protesting were described as
wealthier
more upper middle class more successful
business owners and i noticed something
interesting
that in a lot of places you you
mentioned that people always buy this
this lie that we're going to take from
the rich and give to the poor
well it's simple they're they're they're
saying we're going to give you stuff
and so for these people who are living
you know it doesn't matter what class
you are
being told you're going to get free
stuff people are like i'll take stuff so
what ends up happening is i see i see
this with you know occupy wall street i
see with other protests and other
countries
there in many ways you'll see the poor
people
will protest when conditions are bad for
the poor and then when you get this
inversion like in venezuela where they
take away the property from the
middle class it was actually middle
class and upper class people protesting
because they couldn't
they couldn't survive they couldn't
succeed and they're the ones producing
in the country so it was interesting
it seems like in you know the the
rightists or whatever are they they're
of course going to oppose
this effort to strip away the wealth and
the resources they build and give it to
other people
i don't see how it's noble or honorable
to take from somebody
who has made a bunch of things by force
within reason mind you
to just give it away to everybody else
arbitrarily especially when there's no
agreement there's no
social contract and that's one of the
biggest problems we have today which is
why so many libertarians say
taxation is theft um i think there is a
line
but i i do find it to be particularly
interesting long story short
it doesn't matter if it's communist
china it doesn't matter if it's cuba
venezuela or even the united states
now in the united states they're saying
the oppressors and the oppressed and
they're using race to get what they want
so now you have this idea i guess
they're claiming
who are they claiming are the oppressors
now typically whites is heteronormative
men
right you have your own new oppressors
groups
in oppressed groups but say to me though
it's not even about race or skin color
it's really about the cultural
revolution
like a male did right because malware
used a critical class series
to destroy thousands of years of
chinese civilization culture and
religion arts one-third of cultural
relics
were destroyed yeah taiwan hong kong
people preserve
more of traditional chinese culture even
beautiful
you know like chinese dresses were
banned to wear
during mall time i could not lay my hair
down like this
it's old style i cannot wear beautiful
sexy women's dresses
because that was capitalist so
everything has to be in nine conform
to collective society well here's what i
think happened uh
in china it was mostly mostly ethnically
chinese so critical
people critical class theory is what
you'd have to use right in order to
create your press and oppressor
uh the critical race theorist notably
kimberly crenshaw wrote
that uh in her book critical race theory
that they called it critical race theory
so that people would understand
that it came from critical theory from
marxist ideology and the idea conveyed
in the book is that
marx didn't understand the racial
dynamics that
happened in the united states about who
is the oppressor and who is the
oppressed and he seems to think you know
his ideas of class
only work in these old world home you
know ethnically homogenous places
so they needed to create a new framework
that was
race-based for the us and this was back
i think was like the late 70s early 80s
and now it's come straight to the
forefront you know some 30 40 years
later
now it's in our schools they're lying
saying it's not in our schools but
what's it
what what they've done is they keep
changing the goal they keep moving the
goal posts
oh it's not it's not uh um you know
critical race theory it's something else
oh it's not feminism it's something else
oh we're just teaching people not to be
bigots
and then every step of the way they're
they're indoctrinating into this
this marxist ideology so we get caught
up in things like critical race theory
i hear from all the time from parents
saying critical race there in our
schools and i said have you talked about
critical theory in general or critical
gender theory and they don't
so that's one of the things that keeps
people kind of running in circles is the
con
constant semantic debate but it isn't
our it is in our schools now it's
critical race applied principle
children are being taught all of these
ideas in their in their curriculums
not just as a whole so the teachers
aren't saying open up your critical race
theory books
the teachers are saying open up your
science book and learn about the
critical theory of the frog or something
they're they're injecting the ideology
it's called praxis they're putting it
into the literature now these kids are
gonna grow up and they're gonna they're
gonna believe this stuff they're gonna
be a part of that
so we may be ten years away from
our ideal ideological idealistic college
kids we already have them obviously
but imagine now all these grade school
kids were being indoctrinated imagine
when they're in school
and then there's some charismatic
cultural marxist
leader who comes around he's a little
older and he rallies all of these kids
now who are in their 20s
that could come here and we will face a
cultural revolution in what a decade
well that's one of the similarities i
see
is to indoctrinate
indoctrinate our youth make them
religiously following so-called
social justice movement right and follow
all this critical risk whatever new name
they might give it so basically it is
about uh um equity they just use
race car use gender issues and
you have to use identity politics to
separate your citizens
it's a typical maoist marxist way to do
divide and conquer how do you divide
people
mouthed by classes right five red five
black
and what are the marxists doing in our
country
by race if you trace back those critical
race theory
so people cannot sell communism very
old-fashioned way
by doing oh who is poor who is rich
but they can sell to the country and
people sensitive compassionate
buying the race game race car and look
you know all those people who have
different sexes different genders
different races skin color they are
oppressed but they don't know
oppressor versus oppressed that's
already typical marxist you know
theory mao is the theory then further
divided people into subgroups
you have to get people to fight each
other hate each other
mao said revolution is not dinner party
it's not embroidery revolution is about
crush your enemies with a hammer that's
what a communist party symbol is
right use violence scare people
were you scared last year when you say
what's going on in our streets
mao also use young people to top down
their statues
destroy the culture radix and looting
door-to-door by red cards
drunk hitting go to searching the doors
get ready for all the people have to
burn bugs
hide their old dresses and hide all the
chinese
arts or give them away bury them so they
don't go to
concentration camps people don't get
this don't give us
when the statues were being torn down
these are the stories we read about in
these books
these were the the movies we watched
where you see
the image of the people throwing the
ropes and toppling the statues
we we knew that this was a component of
what was going on and then we watched it
happen for a year and so many people in
this country
didn't care and i saw these
conversations people would say well you
know
christopher columbus is a racist or
whatever and i'm like the point is
whether you agree or disagree violent
groups tearing down statues without
public
conversations without any any democratic
values
these are authoritarians who are
imposing their will on everyone else
and no one asked for this if you allow
these people to keep doing whatever they
want
and that's what's happened eventually
they just take
absolute authority and then what they
will do is substantially worse than what
they're doing now
we had a man uh on the show he was uh
an act he was a freedom fighter in after
the revolution in cuba
he said if these people get real power
they'll start killing people
well they did i mean
how many people died the most sad part
is they get the children turan on their
parents
grandparents and the neighbors
friends i learned my lesson i can't
trust my friends
my friend reported to teacher about i
was bragging about
my good grades in schools as seven years
old
oh she was full of herself she was
overly confident
bragging about her grade she'll be first
one to join mouse
young pioneer group read that red scarf
i was pushed back for a year not to join
mouse
young pioneer to wear that red scarf i
was
red child i was very competitive i
wanted to do it i want to be first group
to wear a red scarf i got a
a spy a friend reported to teachers i
got according to
teacher principal office to say sorry
you're full of yourself in our
collective society
your individual expression confidence
are not
allowed you better to act like one of
the
other students keep your head down
conform
i learned my lesson at the 7 i never
forget that lesson
i never forget to remind myself
don't trust anybody in this society
and i become red guard later and i
become
even communist youth member when i was
in college
and after graduate from law school i
wanted to teach in shanghai i had to
join communist party
in order to teach a university to teach
law
otherwise were your loyalty you know so
i did
all that but i also learned in my back
burner
oh i better not trust anybody i need to
be strategic what i say
is that sad i feel like that way today
about america i have to be careful about
what i said
why not get cancelled it's it's it's
it's history is repeating itself how did
you wake up to what was happening
in china and decide to leave when mao
died
if you go to government schools one
party controls
everything so you go to schools
and you hold a little chair my mouth
read the books and they ask you to
chanting
long live my mouth long live the party
you
literally chant for quite a long time
then you see a song
say hey my parents are dear my mother is
more dear
chia my mouth is the rising sun from the
east
all that stuff right all right we'll
called the red songs
then i never challenged that like oh is
it is mal a god
or human i never asked that question you
were not
allowed to ask those questions either
but my parents were in literally working
poorer class
they they did not ask questions so by
the time mao of sudden died
i was already 12 years old i mean he was
like
my god talking to me from clouds smiling
at me from the burning fire when we do
chinese stern fry you have to put like a
fire under the walk
it's like sometimes because every day
you say chanting
it was becoming like your religion
communism was your religion what was
your god so mom would smile at me
and so if i go to exercise in the
morning
everything is political you cannot just
say i want to exercise
because i want to look strong look
pretty no
not right then to say you should say i'm
exercise
to protect cheer my mouth and to protect
my motherland oh good child good student
you get a pat on the back
so that so i learned to be a straight
red right
oh i cannot really say what i really
feel
but i have to make it pc so i can move
up
so when i woke up mal died that was the
first time in my life
i start to ask myself privately
how how did that happen did
did he die as a human did somebody lie
to me
i had some brain left you know at 12
then then later the communist party did
come out to say
hey mao was a human being cultural
revolution was a mistake
ah i was totally lost
imagine you god is dead
i just said hmm what's going to happen
to me now my generation my parents
generation
and raider guard generation want to
concentrate for 10 years
to to watch him serve him and then later
lost 10 years life without degree
without wife without anything
how about those my uncle generations i
was lucky i did not go to countryside
for 10 years because
i was too young so people who are five
years older seven years older than me
they own the countryside after my use
the young
people he saw them under the bus go to
countryside we don't need you anymore
i'm already become godlike leader
and they they they rule of law
was gone police were told to standing
down military was all loyal to the party
so people were killing people in the
streets
sounds familiar no law no rule of law
low order
defunct police okay so my uncle
generation went to countryside
i was lucky to have even time to ask a
question
what happened so i decided i'm going to
search for truth
by going to the best university which
was all school shutting down
the only cultural revolution and i could
go back to school
and study for a few years before i could
go to college
pass this national college exam so i
wanted to search for truth
of course in law school my dream
my ambition was gone i got lost again
that's when i started to wake up to say
maybe i should
look for other options to get out of
china
i would not be happy and free in this
country
when i went to law school first week our
professor said
what is law it's called a law theory
class soviet union
style law is not what you think because
i thought it was for justice
no law is a tool for the party to use to
govern the masses it's the typical word
the masses you are not the individual
team
you are one of the numbers you are one
of the masses
so that's my truth i was looking for i
could not change in china to a society
rule of law
it would be always ruled by men
by a few mad men dictators who want to
be tyrants and pearls
so i started to become rebellious
college
in the 80s was best years of my life up
to that point
because we were going through cultural
relations
in the 80s and the thin xiaoping said
okay then some people get rich first
little kids
hair laid down they can't wear blue
jeans they can have dancing parties
so i went to dancing party every night
did not even feel like study anymore
just wanted to listen to classic music
and even chinese style rock and roll i
remember i learned
disco in college in the 80s and when i
was already older ryan was
60s disco but in the 80s i was dancing
disco in china
on college campuses that was great first
time you feel the freedom even shake
your body
because you could not even move your
body you cannot dance you cannot sing
songs you love you cannot date
and you cannot wear beautiful clothing i
never know how to do makeup except
lipsticks all work capitalist styles
were banned
so by the time i went to college oh i
could do
this call shake my body anyway i see fit
it was truly a liberation moment
but i was in china yes college campus in
the 80s
wow i was in college 81 to 85.
what if but if that all that good stuff
was happening why would you why would
you leave
well when you work with venice college
student
is one story but when you get a job
by the state everybody got a guaranteed
job
as a college student there was no labor
market yet it was totally still complex
kind of style economy
central planning everybody got a
guaranteed job
so i wanted to stay in shanghai to teach
because
if i go back to sichuan chengdu it was
more isolated it was
less western but we got foreign students
and foreign professors
on our college campuses one american
student changed my life
he told me about america he put
something in my head
hey lily come to my dorm i shoot you
something from america
i saw was some piece of art and cool
stuff he showed me a pocket constitution
wow he was not supposed to
that's why he was not trusted for any
college student to see
a foreign student or foreign professor
you got to register there's an old lady
or old man as a gate
keeper there register my name my major
my dormitory address
what i gonna talk about timing time out
who are gonna visit it's all tracked so
by the time i went to his dorm
he showed me this he told me about
decoration of independence just my
english was so bad i couldn't understand
he just read to me very slowly we held
those choose to be self-evident
what all men are critical what do you
mean
what lily you are woman you are chinese
you have yellow skin
but you are creatures
daughter and son your rights come from
god a lot from your government you have
an individual right
nobody can take away from you that's in
american's funding document
my light bulb just came out i never
heard of individual
right i have a right me by myself
not from my government you know what
next time when i went back to see him
i refused to register my light bulbs
were not turned off it's like i found
some
critical term called the individual
right
from god i but i had to cheat because if
you don't register you get caught the
police were taken away
so i had to use the when lady goes to
put a t go to bathroom
i would sneak upstairs and then we'll
run downstairs very quietly
and he told me more about constitution
separation of
powers and the right to vote bureau of
rights
most important second amendment right
it's like
wow this is a can you imagine my feeling
it's like i have this it's like
finally i was searching for something
and i
found it as a junior year student in
college
but still i wasn't ready to leave china
because i still had
hope to change my country into rule of
law
i just like what i heard from him those
new concepts i just did not want to
complain anymore
so i'm still continue to be with venice
college students
escape classes you know what you do when
you go to college that time
6 30 in the morning it's like a loud
concentration camp
in germany 6 30 in the morning big
speakers come on college campus
time to wake up students time to go to
school time to go to work
you cannot sleep in but you can wait
until that's over be quiet then sleep in
skip classes
so i was very rebellious because i said
what i'm going to study law for
i was told law is not for justice but i
still wanted to try i haven't given up
my dream my ambition yet
but did you see i'm assuming you did at
this time injustice
the the authorities hurting innocent
people arresting and rounding up
innocent people
no government control all radios all tv
stations
all peer articles all newspapers you
only hear good news
but great did you ever witness it
yourself
i witnessed two neighbors
when i was growing up in a community
courtyard
where my parents left with us two
neighbors disappeared
i witnessed people who have better
positions inside the state factories got
a better food rationing coupons
and i had to babysit because everything
they said they said supposed to be free
they were never free except our
community courtyard but
a family here won best bathroom
one water fossil would you like to live
there you know the hell no it's like so
about poverty that was real poverty so
so i went through that
but i did not know how really bad this
is
a
dictatorship one party system is i was
very patriotic
i i was brainwashed to love my
motherland not the party until i went to
college
i become re-business then my night bulbs
came on but i still graduated i got a
job in shanghai to become a faculty
member
of law school that's when reality
kicking i could not even go to dancing
party anymore
because every university department
showed by who
communist party committee they are in
your university
with every department with if you have a
business today private business in china
you have over a hundred employees they
party on your site
supervise you make sure there's no any
threat
to national security so when i become
law school faculty
they say well you got to change you got
to join the communist party because
you teach law law is a state government
tool to govern the masses so i did that
so but after one year i just feel like
oh my god i could not ever have academic
freedom
i could never do what since i wanted to
do so i decided
here's a country called america maybe i
should
plan my escape the uh you need a
permission to leave tim
to get a passport to quit your job it's
not like um to go pack my bag and leave
no
they track you by household registration
so you my household registration was in
chengdu so michael status was my family
in chengdu
but i have my personnel file
individually in shanghai
so i could not just pack up leave you
supposed to stay where you supposed to
stay
so when i tried to come to america
i had to change my attitude i had to
change my
strategies to bother up my company's
party committee for
permission to quit my job to live for
america
it was two years long process and you
cannot trust anybody to tell anybody
i plan to leave i will never go back
so i basically just say well i need to
go to university to get a master's
degree
so i can come home serve my country
better
and so he said well your attitude is not
good you were not speaking up support
party policies during your weekly
political study meetings
so i say okay i'll do better so i
started to go to my weekly meetings
and remember my my live book came on i
was
most time sitting there quiet don't say
anything
because i don't buy into that anymore
but i have to change my
behaviors okay i support the policy
great
good news you wanted to leave so finally
i got
permission to go apply for passport to
go to graduate school in ut
austin texas that was 1988.
so before we get into what it was like
when you first
you know are getting out of china i
wanted to ask you
experiencing you said neighbors
disappeared
yes for no reason and recently recently
one of my junior high school students
used to be on weight check
all for my junior school good friends
in my hometown they don't know where he
is when you so when you were younger did
you understand what it was to have
someone disappeared
no i just know the adults sometimes
whisper
i was a child i lived in their courtyard
until we were about 16 to move
to another better place but this a
family here
korea would never i was always curious
when the people were talking about
something
like comments on society the government
i would like to ask a question they
always say
shh quiet go go there sit there your
child don't say anything
i just heard two people just gone i
don't know what happened to them
not supposed to ask questions and
there's no trial no saying nothing no
notification
don't know what happened did you ever
realize as you got older what was going
on
now i know people disappear all the time
even when i was in law school i did not
know i also did not know
lots of people starting to death i i did
not know any of those
i just wanted to base it i was young i
just wanted to have some personal
freedom
i want to be left alone so i decided
i should come to a free country so i can
be left alone that's all i wanted
i did not know how ugly actually china
society was
what was what was it like to learn of
the first amendment
when you were shown that pocket
constitution
freedom of speech speak and free to
assemble free you know what it's kind of
funny
they had all that in the chinese
constitution too
and a soviet but they never never exist
in reality
they but so why believe them so but the
most important
when he told me that the u.s actually
has a separation for powers
that was most shocking to me it's oh we
have a three branch of government
you get to vote really as a citizen it's
like
really you know my first time i voted in
the united states
it was year of 2000 i was 36 years old
first time to vote in my entire life i
took this
right so seriously where lots of people
don't even vote
but they run over anyway if you don't
vote like some people don't vote but
you know you you if you think
i'm not political i don't need to vote i
don't need to choose my own you know
like the rulers
they don't leave your law they have
interest in you where you are not
interested in politics
they want to control you dominate you
and
take away more of your private property
even you suffer ownership of your body
look at what's happening
last year and this year right so that's
what companies do
so when i realized oh i could come to
this country
later become citizen vote choose who
represents
me that was huge deal of course this
religious freedom we were shut down all
religions during mouse cultural
revolution
my grandmother my mom were buddhists and
all of a sudden we could not go to
buddha's temple to say buddha bless me
anymore
because that was not pc you need to say
long never turn my mouth
don't say long you know buddha bless me
so
i i in order to become young pioneer
rate card
i could not tell people we were
buddhists
that would be stupid that's black class
i think maybe the the most shocking
thing may have been the discovery of the
second amendment
yes what what what were you thinking
when you discovered americans can just
have guns
i could not even comprehend that
and i could not comprehend that i just
thought are you sure
are you sure because in china it's in
nico
you go to straight to jail right
i want to tell you funny saying when i
first came to this country
i was afraid of guns i was free to touch
it it's like a guy who's gonna jump on
me and kill me or something
then my husband i'm married to a texan
right i went to gun range
and he they showed me first time i went
to gun range i scared
them a lot because i just said oh what
is this
people say oh no no no later you you
never pick up gun like that
that's not responsible you could kill
somebody you number one rule
you never point at the person right so i
said okay
so they show me how to use it and how to
practice
this or that so i started to feel a
little bit comfortable
and and when i fired first shot it was
very scary it was
loud even though i had a year plug and
then kickbacks like oh
it was horrible i was horrible i said oh
it's better i don't touch guns so i
would still freak guns
but after it becomes and especially
let the pm square massacre happen
when you say citizens and the students
peaceful protesters were slaughtered
and i start to really appreciate a
second amendment
you could beg the tankers soldier to
stop please don't kill our student there
are other brightest best
like the beijing citizens did
so then xiaoping had to get those troops
from outside of beijing
because beijing soldiers could not do it
because they know they know oh they're
just peaceful protesters
they just won't have a dialogue with the
party officials
they were not talking about virtual
government at all so then xiaomi went
area to get the troops coming they're
all indoctrinated
we have a country revolutionary in the
beijing
go to crush them they knew the power of
college students they used the the young
ideological college students in the
first place
so naturally they understood that these
these people would bring about change
yes they stopped them so so if you're
not in line
your legionaries very sad since 1999
the case is sealed those students
are counted revolutionary according to
china's law
so their moms dads were waiting for
years trying to get the case overturned
they couldn't do it it's a banned word
on the internet you cannot even search
german square music did you know about
tiananmen square massacre when you were
living in china
oh i was here in 1988 okay so i watched
the whole thing i was so sad
and i had a friend who worked for xinhua
news agency in beijing
they were there for entire six weeks
peaceful period just feels
excited and they were just hoping of
no no no crackdown no no we just want to
have dialogue
we're not the country revolution we're
not violent criminals
and they heard the gunshots
one girl came back to office xinhua news
agency
the propaganda arm of a chinese
communist party
young college graduates that night all
cried
they lost hope my friends i don't know
where they are today
gang you think the state took them
some disappeared someone to jail i think
this guy who worked for xinhua music
i think he left country i don't know
where he's today
maybe australia i don't know he
shouldn't find me if he knew i i'm in
america
but i don't know where they are he even
told me i'm not gonna have children i'm
not gonna get married
maybe that's the you know least thing i
can do
so called contribute to my motherland
i'm gonna be gone i'm not gonna have
kids in this country
so most educated people are gone you
know i could not imagine
wanting to leave america i i understand
though
actually i did that back united states
and then
working for companies where i've
traveled all over the world i've seen
how amazing america is
because you take it for granted not
being here or you take it for granted
being here i mean
when i started traveling around covering
conflict and crisis in other countries
and then seeing what the rules and the
laws were
i was in thailand for instance you
couldn't even
paraphrase disparagement of the royal
family it's les might just stay it's a
crime
even as a journalist to say if let's say
you know ian disparaged
the crown i could not as a reporter say
ian crossland made a comment dispatching
the crown
that itself was a crime and so i
remember having conversations with
foreign journalists
and one accidentally and referenced
someone insulted the king
and then panicked and started looking
around making sure because even as a
foreigner you can get in trouble
yes then i come back to america and i'm
going through the security line and i
see the the the border cbp
and they're looking like yeah yeah yeah
and i'm like i see the american flag and
i'm like wow
i know different huh i can say screw off
to the president all day and night and
laugh
and i can say it into the face of these
federal these federal agents these
officers
and they'd look at me like a weirdo and
i'd be like hey i'm just saying it's i
love america
i didn't say that obviously i'm saying
like you can you you
and and it's crazy now with what we're
seeing with all this critical race
theory stuff
now i understand when when i hear these
stories about
cuba venezuela china the soviet union
that if these things do keep happening
here in the united states and they do
get as crazy as
they get crazier than they are then i
would understand you know why someone
would flee their country and that's
scary to me because
america is the last best hope i guess
i mean there's a lot of countries in the
world some of them are pretty good
uruguay is pretty chill
but america is is something unique with
that constitution that bill of rights
and if we don't defend it and we lose it
then
what what do we have where do we go
that's why i properly
come out and i funded with another
vietnamese american
uh new hampshire asian american
coalition
our first rally was about
and stop critical race theory
indoctrination
we had 250 people showed up and
we had about 12 people on this stage
when we ended the event holding
signs all men are critical in their own
native language
japanese tai chi and you know
all kind of languages to say you know
what people even don't know what we're
saying
we just hold the signs and say this one
short sentence
until the last guy and and and he's
black
and he holds the sign said beautifully
like
oh man ah critical then we play the song
the charts called the american the
beautiful
it was a very positive unifying moment
all those immigrants come from all over
the world
think america is exceptional country
the only country you can come
to achieve american dream i get
emotional when i think about that
like american dream where can you
achieve american dreams
and i was just so touched by watching
them oh my god it's like
we defend america america is
not systemic racist country
otherwise why would we all want to come
you know sorry about that it's a good
emotion
and i agree i grew up here i grew up in
chicago
i grew up being told a lot of things by
leftists anarchists you know we didn't
have critical race through back then but
we certainly had class theory
and so when i was younger i heard all
about you know
the one percent the rich and i have i
still have some some um
libertarian i consider myself to be left
libertarian i think libertarian comes
first in that
you can't force people to do things you
have to come to agreements and find
cooperation and negotiate there has to
be
mutual agreements and it really wasn't
until uh
i started traveling the world and seeing
what other countries are like
then i start to realize man we really do
have something special here
i think america has has its share of bad
history it doesn't the history of the
world is fairly bad but we've certainly
made something special and i think you
hit the nail on the head
if it really was so awful and racist why
would everyone want to come here
well that's why i feel like uh you know
i learned about little slavery history
you know
no country is ever perfect and we all
have our issues we need to deal with
that's why it's so important for all
these citizens
with diversity ideas minds
thoughts skills to come together have
conversations how are we going to solve
our problems we face how we're going to
help our
communities our families america is
about
we all are multi-part immigrants from
somewhere
many years ago how
how could we condemn each other how
could we call it
if you were born white you're racist
your ancestors were racist
but i i come here i'm supposed to be
victim
oppressed as a chinese immigrant i came
here with nothing
nothing a hundred dollars borrowed
and i own my professor sponsor twelve
hundred dollars in debt
i could not even speak english i was
about 24 years old
i walk away from a country my family
friends
and inner foreign land and american
people open their
arms to welcome me to offer me their
homes
free items kitchenware blankets clothing
because i was a poor graduate student
and i lived in austin texas a
traditionally very wide neighborhood
it was so warm to me let's start from
the beginning because we we we left off
you know you had just you had left china
so tell me what it was like you
you're finally leaving china coming to
america you knew and no one else did
you had been planning this for years
convincing everyone around you
that you loved the party that you were
working for the party and that with your
new degree from america you could come
serve
the chinese communist party but really
in the back of your mind once you got on
that plane
you were gonna go across that border in
america you were gonna stay in america
so
so what was that like so when i get the
permission to leave
here's a trick my party boss said
okay i will give you paper to go apply
for your passport even though i got
into graduate school on my own time on
my own time my own efforts find american
sponsor all that stuff
then he said you must come back serve
your country
write down sign disagreement or two
conditions
two consequences we're gonna kick you
out the party number one
i didn't care about that right that's no
big deal you know i didn't want to join
in first place
number two i told you about household
registration
where you supposedly were you registered
as a family which is chengdu
then your personnel file who travel with
you secret file
that the chinese and communist party
officials and your employers share with
each other
yo they're not allowed to say what's
inside your family parents were never
allowed to say what's inside
my personal file was in shanghai with me
when i was working in shanghai
if i don't go back that to set my fail
back to chengdu
so try western province lexi tibet so i
will lose
opportunity to have a better career
better living standard better pay
in shanghai getting my law school job
back
that was tough one that really pushed me
to the corner i better make it in this
country i don't know how
i didn't have anything to start with
couldn't even speak the language
i just had this big ambition and big
determination i'm gonna make it
i'm gonna make it i don't wanna come
don't wanna come back to this one party
rule state
i want to be free i want to have
prosperity
i want to get rich that's how i told my
friends
please i'm going to america i need a
hundred bucks
i do not have the money ten dollars here
write down their name
ten dollars here borrowed i'm gonna get
rich i'm gonna pay you back
20 interest how is that i raised a
hundred dollars come to this country
and but i was still i was still a little
bit scared
because i really don't know how i'm
going to pay bills you know what i feel
so blessed the first night
i come to this country my sponsor picked
me up
1988 may 11th at austin airport
let's go say your neighborhood because
he lives next door to my on graduate
school thing so let's go say hi to your
thing first
i am tired i was air sick i threw up
during my flight i looked pale then my
whole family is waiting
so i showed up at the door lock on the
door
and here's this very earthly mother like
dean professor said welcome to texas
with a garden rose a red rose from her
garden
and then she turned around to say meet
my oldest son
zhang and then another son
you know other kids behind zhang so i
met my future husband
the first night i arrived in austin
texas
and i thought i just came over from one
point some two billion in chinese
and he looked really dark blue eyes and
big nose so i saw
he looked alien like and but he was very
nice
to me and he said would you like to
visit campus next day
and very slowly when english was not
good i said okay
okay i was they thought i was shy but
because i could not speak english i was
tired i was sick
so next day he took me to tour the ut
austin campus
and took me to dinosaur museum and all i
heard is swords and sources source i
don't know what kind of dinosaur
i said can i go home sleep and i'm
retired and he was very patient
so i learned english from him i will
write down my new vocabulary
find the dictionary to learn english and
his mom was next door
later when i needed a place to stay and
then his mom and next-door neighbor
they'll offer me
free room to stay so i could pay back my
debt
and for two months as a research
assistantship
i only made 500 a month but when i got
my first two months
check oh that was such a wonderful
feeling i was lying in bed
look at my first two months salary 900
dollars for two months
and i could not sleep i was so excited
because that time one dollar equals to
five chinese yen or something
that was lots of money the most money i
never made i did not own anything in
china
i did not even own myself i only had a
used bike
so now i have 900 dollars in my check
oh i was exciting you know when did you
tell people that you were not going back
to china and what was that like
well what happened the 1989 tiananmen
square massacre happened
so they did not single me out because
400 000
chinese students got the ambush
refugee status because if you protest
they raise money which we did
you could go to china face potential on
student visa
if we go to china they can stop me to
say you cannot come back to united
states
that my nightmare will happen again so
i had to convince my family to say he's
really nice guy here's a
mom dad brother sister and traditional
texas nice family what they do
their pictures and here's john's picture
and me
i see to pretend he's like a very
excellent chinese young man
except he has blue guys and big nose you
know
they'll say okay let's give her a lesson
so then she can come home with
guaranteed return
ticket so we i marry myself out
in a church and my sponsor was my
acting father to give me away and
i had a godmother in texas and she act
like my mother
and it was beautiful wedding and but i
did not have anybody from my
family to attend i had their family
portraits on the table
in the church to say hey they're
watching me
that's how i married myself then took my
husband back to visit
and they all loved him but why wouldn't
the the party
make you stay then after i mean you had
been gone you
you broke the rules didn't you well
because they i'm just one of the 400
000 people i did not go shanghai to work
they probably you did not know i went
back to visit it
because i did not go to say can i have
my job back well i couldn't
have my job back this is my already
broke the rule right
but in order to go back and i still had
the chinese passport that time
and it was okay because i was one of the
four hundred thousand students got a
political refugee status because the u.s
government
offered that so i was lucky in that
regard i could go back to find my family
they saw my children later
you know they and this little party for
us like
it's like a waiting celebration
afterwards we got married but
in chinese style you know you were you
were saying that
you know even in in china like a couple
years before you left you had been
planning this thing you had been
rebellious do you think you would have
been protesting
during the the time square protests or
in any way i don't think you were there
you weren't right i was in shanghai not
in beijing
but the june 4th tiananmen square
student protests were happening all over
the china
so when i went back year of like 1990
with my husband
guess what my family act really weird we
will say hi to neighbors i have friends
come over have a big face
when everybody's gone just my favorite
uncle and his wife
left in the room then they locked the
door
now tell us what do you know
see wow they were asking me what do i
know
about the tiananmen square 1989 what is
a foreign press saying
what did i see on tv i told them the
truth
they did not know the truth but they saw
with their own eyes
students even in chengdu protested and
got
crushed so the crush of students is
everywhere in china not just in beijing
i'm only saying you song cnn
but they were all over i had a friend in
shanghai he
got through into jail he came to this
country later
as graduate student and swear to god he
will never go back to china he even
become
christian and he's working living in
north carolina
he said no i will never go back probably
he's on blacklist he went to jail before
right
because he doesn't have a good record to
go back to and
so we we talk sometimes and and he's
very busy now he's not
very politically active but he tell me
though oh
i really don't want to go back to china
you know i don't care
i i care more about what's happening in
america now
oh i i was thinking when you were saying
they locked the door and they were
asking you in the room
what happens like now today they can
listen with like
telescopic radio and and listen to
people talking in their houses
lasers on a window how difficult it is
to get the information around
when the government goes haywire it's
getting more it seems like it's getting
more difficult maybe it's getting easier
too in some ways that i don't know
underground it's all social media now
called the weight chair
you have groups so you have to be
careful in china
and people um i don't know what they do
with their cell phones when they talk
about sensitive stuff
because everything can be tracked by
your cell phone so
chinese government even banning cash now
every
financial transactions is your cell
phone
when you go get your cell phone brand
new cell phone the cell phone company
which is seen by governmental they scan
your face
they get your voice recording then give
you the number
then hook up with your bank account and
now
your vaccine record vaccine passport
sounds familiar
so everything is on your cell phone
everybody has a cell phone it's very
cheap to get
then they built 4g 5g network all over
the country
300 300 million
public facial recognition cameras
in public places in china today in a few
years will be 600
million for every two citizens in china
you have one camera watch you and those
are huge cameras not like little traffic
cameras you saw here
huge i saw them before and they are in
xinjiang
the weaker place everywhere watch people
you could not even talk to your
relatives overseas without somebody next
to you
listening say what you're saying so it's
a
people always say why chinese just
comply i said well
first of all the government propaganda
got lots of people in the cities
brainwashed some
even think social criticism is good for
the society
all the bad behaviors are gone but
how about citizens voices
how about dissidents voices ah doesn't
matter
you know so if your social critic school
system
your score is low you cannot buy train
tickets to travel
forget about flying forget about get
your passport leave the country
and your kids cannot even go to good
schools you cannot get
mortgages and you cannot even say
something
on your way check because your account
were shut down hey sounds familiar in
america
you self-censor all the time
don't say anything then you will get
shot down or you score below
you cannot get a job your kids cannot
get a care benefits
cannot go to good school now they're
forcing people
getting vaccinated and everybody
has to no exceptions and
i i some people will cross the
firewall which is the internet blocker
use a vpn
and watch my video interviews maybe
hopefully they will watch this one too
and they will tell me lily please tell
americans
don't let america to becoming like china
because we have a hope in china if
america is free
and you tell them you tell them don't
become like
us you speak for us wildest people in
china
every time when i get a message like
that i'm just like so move touched
it gave me more courage to continue to
speak up
in the same way i do here so you you
came to america
and it was a lot better and you had uh
you you got married you had kids
you had a good life at what point did
you start to see the signs
in america that was similar to what was
happening with the communist party in
china
i was very naive when i first come to
this country i
feel so happy so free even though i did
not have
money did not speak english i just
focused on school
english culture and of course dating
young we got married 18 months later
once we get married we focus on our
graduate degree we finished graduate
degree took him back to china i was
pregnant with our first son boom boom
boom since it happened very quick
so guess what happened you got to make
money after graduating you got to get
jobs
so you have to get the jobs and raise
kids and
for 20 years i was not political
i just wanted to live in peace in
and trying to achieve my american dream
my husband had a student loans
we were even sent to hong kong worked
there for two years and he paid off all
his student loans with my help i got a
full-time job too
doing international trading hong kong
1996-98
i love hong kong it's so sad what
happened today
but then i come back to this country
what happened is my american dream
got interrupted i got laid off by
corporate work
i was in telecom industry 2000 collapsed
so i got laid off and we had a big house
mortgage to pay
our you know dream house with three kids
i started my business i always wanted to
be self-employed
so but my first eight years not
profitable
but that gave me time to study english
totally get involved i said well since
i'm american citizen now
i better learn how this democracy works
so i start to read i start to go to hoa
meetings
i become like a board member of hoa
charter school board member later
chairwoman a fire principal
on my watch and still i wasn't
threatened
until i go to state capital to become
student inter
for free to learn how state capital
state government is running
and i saw all the people there asking
for
taxpayers money all special interest so
i told my husband
i was kind of depressed today i went
there
nobody represent us middle class working
man woman who pay taxes risk family
all special interests lots of
bureaucrats there's representing
their special interests organizations
government
agencies but i still was focused on my
business
tried to make money i got even involved
2009 in real estate
the only reason i woke up is uh i was
independent for many years i become
republican
and around 2008 when crash happened with
when they when banks were bail out
i got really upset free market
failed now we need to build the banks
tarp money remember the bailout and that
all the patriot
act start to track american citizens
privacy it's like oh something's not
right here
and i start to have better english read
the books
and study history and i even read this
book really opened up my mind called
free to choose free mark economics
milton friedman
then later you know the evidence
shrugged
it's like all that just i never heard
this ideology before
only know two parties i only know
government do some government do this
government help us
i never thought about there are other
options it's called free market
a free enterprise and
private charity and the private
community individual help each other
so i start changing i start to go into
some
different kind of meetings and then the
more
i got involved with politics the most
scared i become
why why are people using marxist terms
this country
why are they talk about government
should be bigger and bigger
and the free stuff give people free
stuff and turn people renowned
government
you know how dangerous that is when you
renounce government
they take everything away overnight they
enslave you
they track you you do what i say or what
don't give you food i don't give you
health care i don't give you schooling
so i
become more libertarian say oh we need
to have a bigger individual smaller
government
so i started to get more active in
politics my first time testified
ever it was colorado state house
they're trying to ban our magazines
limited magazines
for ar-15s so i wonder testify 2013 even
wrote my first
opinion piece published to say
we don't want this here otherwise look
the chairman's
square massacre maybe people will fight
instead get killed run over by
government we cannot compromise the
second amendment
that's the first time i testified and
but then they pass anyway
party line so i've become liberty
activist
ever since 2014. i run for state house
in colorado
and i got involved with libertarian
party because i left the republicans
when when they upsetted me when they
left me i saw they left me they left
their own platform behind
and i just care about our liberty i
don't care about all those politicians
rhetorics
now i run again 2016 because 2016
running for u.s
senate gave me unlimited time to talk
about my stories
to get interviews like this in colorado
and
i thought wow actually whenever i go
tell my stories people give me big hands
i need to do more of this they obviously
want to learn more about my stories what
happened to us so i volunteered to be
speaker in the classrooms
for middle school high school college
students so i had a sponsor called the
victims
of communism memorial foundation based
in dc
i'm on their speakers bureau so students
teachers principals could request or we
need eyewitness of communism
from china to speak to us then boom i
will fly there
go to the classroom teach students it
was so
satisfying when i saw students eyes
open up like this like i did
when i was a senior like a junior year
in college
when i heard those new concepts right
our
students don't know much about horrors
of communism
that's why they're also our schools
are one side dominating they do not
teach you all kind of ideology for you
to choose
no how many students heard about
libertarianism how many students
have heard about other philosophers it's
all about
marxism now divide and conquer they
don't use marxism but they talk about
race
1619 critical race theory
equality diversity including training
america is a racist country mass is
racist
how crazy is that two plus two equals
five yes
so number one rule for the party
i know this just like in 1984 number one
rule
party is always right number two repeat
this same talking pores every day even
though they're big lies
every day repeat it every day same time
everybody every media the lies
will become truth people will no longer
question
is united states learning from chinese
communist party tactics
why if they are taking their
hard core tactics why we're going to ask
that question
i'm sorry yeah
so american citizens
need to ask more questions and it
doesn't matter how
much you're afraid to be caught you are
racist
uh that's why i like hearing it from
your perspective because it's not just
like
it's like i'm able to figure it out on
my own through your
vision like kind of seeing what you saw
it's almost like i went through it
so i'm able to re-realize how important
it is you you you mentioned uh the
democratic
uh do you see the democratic party or
the american government whatever but uh
i'll just i'll just rephrase it
we had a jackpot on the show and he's
mentioned this a couple times that
we all believed that if we opened up to
china and we went there and said look at
all of our amazing capitalism look at
our amazing constitution
that they would say this is brilliant
and we want to adopt it
instead what happened was that many
politicians went over to china
and said wait a minute you built this
building
how fast was it done you mean you just
snapped your fingers and you just
removed the residence and then get to
build your building you mean you built
this road in how many
days wow in america we have to deal with
all this bureaucracy
how do we do it and so the idea i
suppose is that what ended up happening
was americans realized
that it's faster and easier if you just
trample over people's rights and the
chinese communist party certainly
figured it out
now they started importing that here
why why bother with going to a court
to because you've got to deal with one
person's rights
it's like that movie up you ever see
that movie up where the old man has the
home
and the city is built around it but he
won't sell it and they want to take it
from him but he refuses
so what starts is this little house on a
hill
and then after you know 30 years or so
there's skyscrapers everywhere
they want to build the building but his
house is still there and they can't just
take it from him
well that movie wouldn't happen in china
move your ban
but if you made the movie up in china it
would be three minutes long where the
guy says you can't have my house and
they say you never own the house in the
first place and then they just steamroll
it and then build a building
well during the urbanization process of
china so-called modernization building
you know skyscrapers high-rise housing
they actually dislocated lots of people
and you talk about admin domains bad in
america
talk about china you know
they i have a friend in new york city
now she's a political refugee
she had a 10 years 15 years factory
producing product services
during the economic boom and she got
rich because of that
all of a sudden the local government
said
we need your land to build
high-res housing because land belongs to
the state
remember all the lands all the natural
resources belong to the state in china
if you build something it's only the
structure on top of the land
is yours but even for that they want to
flat it and she went to court did not
want to
abolish her factory then court even said
it is her factory you cannot do this
it doesn't matter one party rule they
control courts
they control everything so the local
government like mafia
they both her factory and
she had to flee to come to this country
in order to try to
get her story told she even tried to
handle her paper to the
and she when she was visiting here so
when people talk about oh it's so
efficient
for the chinese government to build this
build that
they're also a very interesting invasion
to put one million people
in concentration camps in xinjiang today
and
harvesting people's organs and arresting
these pure human rights lawyers and the
citizen journalists who don't have a
license to practice to report
so do we want to become like them
democracy constitutional republic
you have a process everybody is entitled
to fair trial
fair process of voting to decide what to
do you cannot just
wipe out like a durian last year your
constitutional rights don't even matter
because we have a pandemic maybe chinese
leaked pademic
virus with purpose of awake our economy
and cancel all western countries
citizens rights
so will be taken over by communists you
know what i
i've been saying is to the people who've
read the books
like 1984 did you think
that the totalitarian regime wouldn't
have an excuse
did people believe when they read 1984
that the party that seized control one
day just got up and said we are taking
control and everyone said okay i guess
no it's always an excuse it's like v for
vendetta
you have you seen v for vendetta you
should definitely see that movie it's
great movie
yeah it's a great it's well it's it's
it's a graphic novel series
um but the movie is fantastic and it
it's
a story about a totalitarian regime it's
in the uk
and for them it was it was a virus there
was i think it was called the saint
mary's virus in the film that
people got scared pharmaceutical company
then started coming out with the cure
that made tons of people rich the party
members all coincidentally got
really wealthy and it was their excuse
for seizing control
people were scared and so they gave up
that control but there's always
some excuse i love animals have you read
animal farm oh yeah
it's also george orwell and it's
basically i read it after i read 1984
but it's like
a version of what could lead up to 1984.
yeah you see the farm and the workers
take over because the farmer's not doing
a good enough job
they throw them out then the smartest of
the workers seem to take control of the
party
and the pigs it's a short book and
they're famous saying that there are
some animals always more equal than
others that's right i know that like
today our tyrants governors
mayors and all the public health and
bureaucrats politicians
we get to told stay home no travel don't
say goodbye to your loved ones
and shut your business for public goods
that's what they told us in china
it's always excuse to take away your
rights and liberty
it's for public good it's for public
health it's for society's stability
and you're not human beings you stay
home you must do this you must do that
do they have this authority to tell
another human being
those people are not gods they're not
angels they're not even
actually decent politicians the
corrupted tyrants
and they tell me how to live my life
here that's like a hell no
hell no we need to march like european
people did last weekend like
the great people did last weekend way
people who love freedom who have human
dignity need to
you light in the world there are so many
tyrants
all want to become the rulers the
masters
to control us to have so much power is
there nice like a load of rain i'm gonna
wear this one ring
i have an unlimited power i watch those
movies
it's like wow absolute power corrupts
absolutely and what is wrong with
americans today who believe authority
if you sell you fear you're gonna just
lie down live on your knees and stay
home
and shut your business government give
me some unemployment checks
give me some stimulus and now inflation
is coming
it's like largest increase on your taxes
when inflation is so big
it hurts a working class it hurts the
poor but they don't understand economics
oh how come our kids don't even stop a
book called economic economics 101
that tells you they don't want you to
become smart you want to dump down you
that's
easy to sell your fear because you're
afraid if you're afraid you'll stay home
you're familiar with uh alexandria
ocasio-cortez of course i can't
debate her but she totally grows me
because i'm nobody
she has an economics degree and recently
on twitter
failed to define capitalism she had
started a business she was selling
merchandise she was criticized for
engaging in capitalism and being a
socialist and then she said that that's
not capitalism
capitalism is when wealthy people
exploit the working class
and just some very ideological and
biased view of what capitalism actually
means capitalism actually is a really
simple definition the private
uh private markets private enterprise
the private exchange of goods and the
private trade
and socialism is the public control of
of the means of production so
a capitalist system there there and
there and there's uh um
in betweens you can be you have a mixed
economy we have a bit of a mixed economy
yeah we don't have total actually pure
capitalism at all
that's why people cannot understand when
they support bernie centers
and demonize capitalism they think what
we have is
corporatism is capitalism so they feel
like
injustice of of course there's lots of
income
gaps and there's a super rich and super
poor you know you have that in all this
society
but what is our alternative you want 100
million people die
and you want to one percent ruling class
over you so
what is alternative which is that's why
we need to have a conversation
how we're going to improve our lives
through more
like a fair competition that means we
actually free market real free market
capitalism everybody's equal
instead of we're talking about oh only
they
billionaires they can shut you down they
can lock you up
and they can sell you the things you
must buy because no more competition
left
because they want to make more money
that's not real capitalism let's
embed with government to have a monopoly
that's totally wrong that's not fair to
regular common man
there's never going to be the equality
in
in terms of class the way these these
class theorists believe
that you could implement comp communism
and then all of a sudden people are even
uneven footing
because some people are still going to
be taller some people are still going to
be shorter
some people are still going to be faster
or stronger or weaker
or slower and some people are going to
be smarter
and the smart people will figure out how
to navigate these systems and
succeed and the people who aren't as
smart will probably struggle in that
regard
and there's nothing you can do to change
it i i don't these
these people don't understand they think
everyone must be equally as smart as
each other they think everybody's the
same height everybody's the same speed
if if we're in in the middle of the
woods and a grizzly bear or
how about a black bear that's charging
at us well the taller faster person's
not going to get eaten
the world doesn't we can complain that
it's wrong that it sucks
that the world is this way right they
don't want to accept that
right team that's why equity is a
marxist term they want the equal outcome
that's what the com cambodia communists
did
they want everybody even look the same
if you wear glasses you get
killed if you're too tall you will cut
your legs half
because we want everybody to look the
same is that insane
and the people buy into socialism
communism because he sounds
utopian sounds wonderful but it never
came
mao promised land to the peasants
intellectuals to have free
idea free expectations then he never
give the land to peasants
he never gave her intellectuals and even
the journalists
the freedom to practice to speak up
lots of journalists in the country are
leaning left
they really don't understand history
either teachers too
they were indoctrinating colleges
training teachers
all about left marxism because it sounds
wonderful
they're compassionate i understand but
the thing is when you look at the system
when you when you look at actually what
happened when you went to that kind of
system
only one percent ruling all equally poor
people you don't get what you wanted you
decided for
and you were being slave because
everybody is relying on government
instead of yourself
responsibility families churches
communities the results just disastrous
it's a lot worse than what the bernie
sanders would like to believe
or they'll say i would like to talk to
her if she wants to sit down with me i
invited her to sit down with me
so now with the lockdowns you know we
saw these videos of nurses dancing in
the hallways there was one viral video
where uh a woman was filming them
rehearsed their dancing and she said you
can hear say
she's filming it is this why we can't
get any help what are they doing
and then you can see the nurses they're
dancing in one video the nurses are
dancing with a mock
corpse that says covid19 it's got a toe
tag on it these are
disgusting and disturbing videos but
they're telling you you can't visit your
loved ones on their deathbed
you can't be there for the the birth of
your children the death of your parents
seeing all that stuff
my question is it's happening all over
the world
is it would you compare it to communist
china and
what do you do when do you try and leave
and where would you go
well i have no place to go america is
home that's why i wanted to tell my
stories
to work americans that it's not just
critical risk theory it's not just two
weeks flat
curve it's not just you know like a for
public health and temporary shutdown
it's not
i don't see that i say it's our liberty
and the rights could be gone forever if
we don't speak up
if we don't fight back we don't resist
and
do we want to rule by communists have
everybody
who came here from communist countries
than to condemn america
i have my youtube channel lily tong
williams i'm
gonna get the immigrants come to my
channel talk about their stories
why we choose this country why we love
america
why we reject all this nonsense to call
america
systemic racist country is it really
about race or it's about something else
it's about destruction fundamentally
destruction of america the values
the exceptionism and the constitution
the declaration of independence
to place replacement with what what i'm
going to do
after we destruct we're going to be
equally poor
we're going to have a marxism we're
going to have our children
all become little social justice
warriors don't have any skills
and don't have any love for this country
chinese
government ccp is laughing to the bank
right now
they have infiltrated our society and
see america exactly is where
they want it they are threatening people
like me in this country speak up
against the communism we are traitors
we are counted revolutionary or we are
extremists
whatever they our media rhetoric
are consistent with chinese official
talking points
it's so sad why are they doing that do
our journeys understand if you practice
journalism in china you need to get a
state lines you need to study
german she thought you need to pass a
test
here they are kung yang stuff
that can make them together through
under the bus someday
and the teachers any conscious good
teachers it's time to speak up now for
the children
our country's sick don't teach division
don't teach
hate we need to be united as americans
there's nothing we cannot do
we cannot win if we are united
but they're indoctrinated they they they
believe it all
they they believe every single word of
the ideology even its contradictions
how do you communicate with someone who
isn't interested in the truth but is
only interested in defending their
their ideology or their culture you got
to get them on your side first and the
way to do that is to show that communism
has some benefit in
small groups it doesn't scale very well
but in a family unit
that's a communist yes but these people
don't think they're communists
okay in fact when you tell some of these
teachers what cultural marxism is
they respond by saying that's a
conspiracy theory it's not real
possibly you're probably right a lot a
lot of times but i think tonight if
someone has listened to this [ __ ]
a lot not always yeah there's a
possibility that someone that had
had been in that mindset had listened to
you tonight and now thinks it
differently
that's possible and probable actually um
and it's just one person at a time but
with the video that that scales
so it's 100 million people at a time or
50 million or 10 million or whatever
i know i have people always say that our
people think oh you're just trying to
scare us
we're not companies china this is not
communism and
it's about racial equity it's about
justice i know their words
but i have lived through it lots of
immigrants have lived through it look at
the cuban americans
what they're saying look at the people
who fled former soviet union what
they're saying
we see the writings on the wall we
recognize these signs
we recognize the terms and tactics
when you do the diversity training now
it's like a china's cultural revolution
struggle sessions
you go to a room you keep your head down
you look depressed you apologize for
being white
racist you if you don't even realize oh
my parents actually told me oh man
credit equal i guess i need a deep dig
dig deeper
i have what you call hidden bias
against people of color then you should
denounce yourself
then you should and apologize
and the public is shaming have you seen
public shaming last year don't they
you know riots and dudes publicly
shaming
and people take knees and all that it's
like a
um we still have maybe some time left
to stop this train going down socialist
companies pass
but they are here the train has started
it's going to go down fast if we don't
educate
our citizens and to be united to realize
danger horror we're going to go down
that way
so that's why i'm calling for people to
listen to immigrants like us
who live through it and we don't buy
this whatever left
is trying to sell us our citizens are
not
our enemies they're not doesn't matter
which party you belong to you're
independent
it doesn't matter it's the people who
want to control us
dominate us want to put a chain on our
necks
and the chains around our brain you
cannot even think
those are our enemies they were through
all of us
99 percent of us under the bus
doesn't matter you are supporters or not
you think they're
oh what were you gonna say there yeah do
you think does anything that could have
been done
when mao had been coming to power in the
50s that could have changed
and and made it so it didn't happen
well he did lose a little bit of power
remember
they had a new president and new
after mao and all the people starving to
death mao was
such a supreme leader when people were
starving to death because
all the mayors governors all the leaders
were appointed by the party not
elected by the people so people were
afraid to tell the truth
because if you tell the truth like a
kobe lighting cover up
or like this flooding if you tell the
truth you might lose your job
so everybody trying to tell good news
never report bad news never tell the
truth
so nobody could stop him by the time he
become like a godlike
by starting the cultural revolution so
he purged his political enemies you know
what happened to his
to our that time the chinese president
he was
house arrested he died along like a pig
along on the floor who was that during
what time
what year the only cultural revolution
his name is new saucy
president of china so mao was not
the president was he just a guy just
some guy he was a military
commission chairman he was a communist
party chairman those two jobs
one you control the party when you
control the guns
that's another similarity i see with
today
law enforcement go down and almost like
one party controller can you know
work military it's like it's very
dangerous
when people swear to defend u.s
constitution
and citizens constitutional rights
against domestic
enemy foreign or domestic
and now you got to go through this
so-called
loyalty test almost like you got to be
active anti-racist do we have to play
race car
so the anti-racist people today i think
their practice racism
it's all about your skin color it's all
about your race but nothing
about other stuff like individual
character your mind
diversity of ideas no it's all about
race so they are actually racist
but then you talk about their fascists
and tifa are supposed to be anti-fascist
but what do they do as if uh are they
practicing actually
fascism i think they are because
anybody who against them you could you
can't get threatened mafia can come kill
you
well it's like uh ibrahim kennedy said
what's his real name henry uh
rogers rogers that's just henry rogers
rodgers
henry rodgers what up henry oh ibrahim
rodgers uh it's like he said
in his his world view he wants racial
discrimination
because he says it's the only way to end
past racial discrimination
and that and then he also says that he
wants future racial discrimination but
he's an
anti-racist well it tells you all you
need to know about anti-fascists
their idea is that they're going to
implement authoritarian tactics of
violence
against anyone who opposes them because
well they have to
to defeat fascism because fascism is
also violent
but that also means they have to attack
innocent people too just in case
they'll claim they won't it's propaganda
we've seen them smash the windows
we've seen the photos from germany where
every store front is smashed up except
the one
the one that had the red salute in the
window the fist of the communist party
of china
the symbol of marxism that was in the
window and that was the one storefront
that wasn't destroyed
people tell me all the time really it's
not just america now but america
is our last home so they they all feel
they lost europe
they lost australia i'm hoping
australian people waking up
and you know that there are lots of
things happening all over the world
it's like there is this a huge communism
wave because this virus alone
can shut down all their freedom loving
people's rights
and liberties guess who benefits
who benefits follow the people who
benefit to gain power
and to gain money including our own
government
our own billionaires corporations and of
course
chinese government silk road initiative
they are using lots of money to buy up
foreign companies
corrupted the government some people
think oh they're so smart to build a
silk road initiative they are smart of
course
and they want your
country's support to expand
globally they want to become number one
by 2049 xi jinping said
his china dream china will be number one
dominating
power of the world because of the
lockdown they think that'll happen in
2028 now
that that china will take over the us
economy as the largest economy on the
planet
well let's let's uh let's go to super
chats and see what uh everybody's
thinking if you haven't already hit that
like button subscribe to the channel go
to timcast.com
we will have a members only segment
coming up after this show
at tmas.com about 11 pm but let's uh
read these super chats
rocket rack says you were right about
who owns the culture
i went to barnes and noble for the first
time in years i usually shop online
the majority of the books covered woke
ideology
that's right and i think you know for a
lot of us
uh one of one of the things i'd like to
mention to you lily is
to consider over the last year with all
the lockdowns everyone's forced to stay
inside
people were only communicating through
social media but social media
the opinions you're allowed to have are
regulated by small
companies and by the people who run
those companies like zuckerberg and
dorsey
that meant that conversations that would
normally happen at a bar
wouldn't somebody who might say
something that they truly believe about
the news but that opinion is banned
say the story about hunter biden you're
locked down you can't talk about it
you post it on the internet you get
banned you say learn to code you get
banned
conversations and ideas were purged by
the big tech companies because no one
had any other way to communicate
let's read a little bit more just a
justice dee says hey tim have you
thought about trying to get g
edward griffin on your show he wrote the
book the creature from jekyll island and
he also did an interview with yuri
besmanov
that would be fantastic we will look
into that
okay neo d genesis says
keep up the great work waiting to see
vosh v kirk
as vasha's claims is three right wings
on one and he can't think of anyone to
partner with
he counts you as right yeah i think you
know
i'm like heterodox centrist of sorts or
whatever
certainly i don't like the democratic
party for basically most of the reasons
you've explained what's going on with
them but the republican party doesn't do
anything
party politics i don't like the
republican party either i like the
libertarian party only now because of
the mises caucus
because of dave smith i understand
having to organize for politics but i
don't know why it has to be like a party
why it's got to be like we are here join
us or not
why can't it just be like we're all
saying what we think and you vote for
whoever you want
it's valid access if you are not a major
party
your candidates cannot get on the ballot
there's a very strong
restrictions based on your state some
states are easier sometimes are very
hard
ever since ross pearl run as a third
party independent
got into presidential debate have you
seen any other ones got into
presidential debate
nobody could nobody could it's a
two-party system
dominating the society i wish what if we
had like
all american party huh that would that
would be cool
but they're saying so you know in new
hampshire and republican party
that i i joined there are lots of good
people are fighting the good fight
and uh um colorado they have lots of
work to do and and so so i said it
depends uh i
always respect people i met dave smith i
you know ask him questions
in during pork fest and whatever i put
it you know i put him on the spot
everybody loved it and you know
basically i said you know what
if libertarians want the h.o.k people be
effective
then we need to do something better and
more
something different because we you know
will if country is becoming today
from an immigrant eyes we're going down
this path so fast
all the freedom-loving americans somehow
have a failed what have you been doing
in the past 40 years
you let the radical left control the
educational system
and inducted our children our college
students or our marxists hate their
family hated their country
but they will not move to cuba we cannot
make them to move you could
ship them i donate air tickets you know
i will yeah me too yeah but at the same
time they don't want to they cannot say
where they want to live
but they were just brilliant i have
offered people
i've had these debates on facebook where
people are like oh america this america
that and i'm like
i mean this genuinely i would love to do
a mini documentary with you
you choose the location we cover all the
costs we go with you
we don't impose any of our views on you
we just literally say tell us where you
want to go
show us what you want us to see nobody
would take up the offer
can we call like release the dragon the
idea
the idea was most of these people that i
argue with don't know anything about
these countries they claim
they're afraid to go and they are afraid
to go they are still living with mom
there too
so so some of these countries i've been
to and so i get a discussion with
someone talking
about you know one country or another
and they say they know what it's like
they know what it is or it's better and
here's why it's better or
or it's worse and here's why it's worse
and i'm like i'll pay for your ticket
i'll go with you we'll film it
and we'll let you guide us and we'll
you'll you'll interview whoever you want
they never want to do it it's often
there a lot of decision making is done
by feeling
that's a problem because then when you
start to get analytical and explain the
past and the
how the cycles that it's confusing and
it kind of threatens their feeling their
worldview based on feeling and they
don't have
i've gone i've been in that position so
i understand it i do want to stress
though just for this uh one super chat
yes tomorrow
charlie kirk and vosh will be here and
uh i guess
vosh is saying it's three right wings on
one because ian's right wing
all right like the weirdest thing
i'm the trojan horse yeah i'm right-wing
let's go
everybody's always complaining of the
chat that ian's like a leftist or he's
like
you know he's wrong i'm so glad i like
to wash ian's right wing wow dude i love
that guy even though we disagree on like
all these different things you know
he's like a dnd friend of mine from high
school out of that's as far as i really
hate people to be put into boxes
don't you think yeah that's why i don't
know call myself a libertarian
i feel weird saying i'm a libertarian
because i feel like i'm then becoming
part of this authoritarian process
that's saying
this is a thing but little l a little
libertarian
i am libertarian but i'm not a
libertarian i feel weird saying
right makes sense so i just want to say
for tomorrow uh
i certainly i think one of the problems
of the left is they only learn about
this show
through memes and out-of-context clips
and i think
you know the last time we had vosh on
the show there were a bunch of leftists
actually saying oh
it wasn't that bad tim's actually not
that bad i saw comments where people are
like he's actually seems like someone
you'd want to hang out with but he's
kind of dumb
and so it's like by all means you can
call me dom i don't care but like to lie
about what we believe in what we do on
the show
like they're you know trying to claim
that we do far-right extremist
conspiracy nonsense like every article
we use is certified by newsguard but i
i will talk about far-right conspiracy
nonsense i will talk about far-left
conspiracy nonsense because it's fun
and that's how you understand what other
people think they'll say you push the
conspiracy
you gotta understand it without
believing it so the plan for tomorrow is
uh ian i i have i have asked to just try
and track the super chats yeah so that
we can write down some of the best
questions and potential rebuttals
i'm mostly just i want them to have a
conversation and i don't want to in
you know intervene unless there's a fact
check involved
and i i want to try and mostly i don't i
don't think it's fair if like
you know charlie and i are both yelling
at vosh i don't agree with charlie on a
lot of things he's a conservative i'm
more libertarian but we certainly
probably agree more
on more stuff than i would with wash but
i don't want to do a show where it's
just like
you know a pile on them you know so if
he says something and he claims it's
true and says you know charlie's wrong
i'll we'll look it up and we'll call out
who got to call out when i when i go to
college campuses lots of times
charlie kirk's turning point usa
on that campus normally is my host they
will make a public event
okay we have eyewitness of companies
china come to talk to us about
her stories and everybody's welcome so
sometimes i will get the students
special
students who are in the middle and i
mean i would love some people to come to
challenge me ask me questions or even
protest me right
but they haven't happened yet normally
they just listen to my story
their eyes were very big they were
focused on my pictures and my
my facial expressions so so i think that
uh
you know if people just can be calm and
listen to each other respect each other
differences
this country actually can get lots of
dong you know instead of
i hate you if you just have a different
portrait i'll tell you even people that
are racist
i don't want to stop them from being
racist it's that's
their world view if and that is
acceptable in the united states
i would like to debate it but i'm not
going to tell you you can't have that
thought or that it's battlefield free
speech
anyway right well i i disagree people
need to evolve and we can't do that if
we're shutting each other up
i do want them to not be racist well
ultimately that's my goal as an
egalitarian
persuade them persuade them to yes by
understanding their point of view you
have to sympathize and empathize
i have had conversations with some
racists
uh and rather recently and it's just it
no logic you're right that's how it's
that's why it's hard to change that
because it's it's fearful it's
terrifying and it's scary to think like
if
even if i understand them i might start
to think like that i don't want but
no that's not how it works no no i'll
tell you what happened is i had a
conversation and i was thinking to
myself like
this guy is basically telling me two
plus two equals five like some of some
of these conversations i'm just like wow
these
they really haven't read this they don't
understand this they make way too many
broad assumptions
and it's detrimental to the success of
this country i get it two
two point four plus two point four is
four point eight which rounds up to five
i understand the logic but it's not
lodge
it's not real logic we got we gotta read
some more chats we've got some misuse of
the word logic people
people should not be racist let's read
some more chats mediocre fisherman says
there is
uh more there are more shortages i work
at a metal shop in wisconsin and we are
having a hard time finding metal
wow all right let's see georgie
georgiev says hello tim get vosh and one
of the chinese guests you had
on last month to get together on the
show i want to see how vosh will defend
his views then you know i i respect vosh
for coming on the show now for the
second time
and there's a bunch there's a few other
people who have like first tried to play
games to get on the show and then
didn't come on the show but not want to
come back on the show i said hey josh
come on the show he said okay and he
came on the show and then we argued and
then people said i was dumb and then
other people said he was dumb and i was
like hey man at least we're like having
the conversation
i'm not i don't hate the guy a lot of
people say disparaging things about him
like by all means i'm here to talk
politics not personal
beef and then when we were trying to put
together another
uh uh show i i tweeted at vosh something
he tweeted some about critical race
theory and i said why don't we have you
back on the show then because he said
conservatives don't know what critical
race theory is so we're going to have
charlie kirk and voshon
with a big part of the discussion will
be critical race theory but we'll talk
about everything
it might end up going long maybe i mean
maybe we'll roll initiative
that's a dungeons and dragons things
yeah yeah i think that you know that's
why
this kind of shoes are so important you
know you give people lots of time
to sit down and exchange views i may
disagree with you
you might disagree with me unless we get
each other to listen
to each other's views for a little bit
then present your point
he said i mean what if you have a great
idea
why are you so afraid of talking about
it and debating it
why do you have to use a force to shut
them down i agree i don't i'm i'm not
scared to have uh the only people there
there's two kinds of people that i
wouldn't want to have on the show
spammers people who have no nothing to
say like obviously you wouldn't invite
them anyway
and people who are just drifting like
they're obvious behaviors where their
intent is to drum up drama and cause
problems and just want to you know react
to that i find if you have a really good
idea
it's you can listen to other people for
hours and let them
talk because your idea is so good you
don't need to yell it you don't need to
repeat it you can wait wait let me get
let me finish this
and then you can and then you can say it
if as opposed to someone that
maybe doesn't really believe what
they're saying so they repeat it over
and over louder and louder because when
you repeat a lie enough times
it does have a an impact i'll tell you
one of the one of the challenges that
will definitely be for tomorrow
is gish galloping what's up it's when
someone says a whole bunch of things
really fast so that makes it difficult
to actually
engage good call it's a it's it's a
that's why it's good
we're recording
like i don't care for rules in a debate
i think i i don't like viewing things as
debates i think we should have a
conversation
but i will have to put like a foot down
if someone says like five points at once
like two plus two equals five three plus
three is seven
seven plus twelve is ninety one and i'm
like stop stop stop we have to address
the first one before you can keep saying
things but people do that all the time
they'll be like critical race theories
not being taught in schools it never was
you're wrong about critical race theory
and
marx is right about class i'm like stop
stop stop we need to say the first thing
provide a rebuttal second thing rebuttal
you can't just
so it'll be interesting but let's uh
let's read some more super chats
fun all right let's see
oh hey how's how's it going uh oregon
life says jenk and his goons over at tyt
had
an hour-long bash session on my boy tim
pool today your show is
better by far jank is just pathetic to
be honest i honestly just
don't care jake uh come on the show dude
yeah no i i i i yeah
yeah actually that'd be that i'd be fine
with it i don't care though you know
like we did a criticism of the young
turks and i said
if they say anything i'm not gonna
respond because i don't care i i don't i
don't care to
like if someone says something about me
and insulting me i'm like whatever dude
i got work to do i'm not going to waste
my time
storm viking says tim after one of your
posts today you are clearly in favor of
forced vaccines
you need to be honest with your audience
that built you up
are you for the vaccine or against it
you need to be honest what
what i'm for people talking to their
doctor and figuring out what makes sense
for themselves
i don't think i'm in the vaccine i'm in
favor i said private businesses can
mandate
a vaccine there's so many vaccines in
the world so like be specific
i worked for vice and in order to travel
to other countries in uh and to to
report you needed to get vaccinated the
security company wouldn't work with us
if i wasn't
because they didn't want to deal with
someone who had yellow fever if you
don't like what a private business is
doing in that regard then don't work for
the company
if the government mandates businesses do
it now that's a problem
if a if a pizza shop says we don't want
to work with people who don't
have you know you know this like
vaccines or whatever i'm like well then
like why did he just the pizza guy
doesn't owe you anything
i'm more libertarian than that the pizza
guy does not owe you
a job and if he doesn't want to hire you
then get back to personal choice you
know
when i was in china we had no choice he
just lined up and
they in schools they just boom boom boom
boom give you lots of shots and you know
no parental rights
but here in this free country if you're
adult you have personal choice
if you're parents then you need to make
decisions for yourself and for your
children
you just that's so simple you know it's
not like either for or against you know
respect freedom respect people right to
choose
i think it's a problem when a
monopolistic business starts doing just
thinking that because then you need to
use the government to
enforce a negative right which is you
can't enforce people
to fill in the book but i'm talking
about like you know john's pizzeria it's
got like 10 employees and he's like
here's what i want i'm like
john doesn't know you anything all right
elizabeth carmella says
wow i am enlightened my father retired
navy seal used to talk to me about mao
when i was a teenager i never listened
i didn't understand thought it was
boring i am listening now time to give
dad a call
to apologize a call too apologize
wow yes
all right ghost crusader says god bless
you tim for having people who escaped
communism on your show to tell to show
the truth
you should get my dad on he left
communism communist china at 14 and came
to the u.s
and is a multi-millionaire now parents
sent him here for fear they would kill
him
wow yeah um wow
how do we uh ghost crusaders i don't
know how to get in touch with you is it
you can
look me up on twitter follow me and
tweet to me what's your twitter
uh sour patch lids there you go that
would be really interesting yeah
archangel says this lady is awesome and
very based lily
thank you thank you very much i
appreciate that comment
all right let's see what we got here
curtis reynolds says god bless this
woman and god bless the usa
absolutely did you are you very
religious did you used to be or did you
become more religious or less religious
as you
transition from china to the united
states you know i i i'm just like
i'm like i i'm not um religious
i do go to churches because i'm
open-minded about learning different
religions
i'm you know very firm supporter of
religious freedom
but what happened to me i think make me
just really really
like an independent or um cautious now
so i have to skeptical yeah i always
have to ask a lot of questions
so you need the time to study religion
to really because
i was raised as buddhists but then we
got shut down during the mouse it was
like
you know now it's like okay you know
like i'm open-minded
i mean i always support people whatever
religion they practice
based on their personal choice but what
they're saying is though that uh
and i think there's a tendency there are
more people
trying to look down on people who are
christian conservatives
but then the people who don't have
religion
they believe in government that's even
more threat to me
it's another religion that's a very
that's more scary
all right this one's important we have
return of the mack he says
groundbreaking interview
stream is shadow band can't find by
searching for it and not showing under
your channel sad day for american right
also many of you may have noticed the
stream was cutting out for some reason
it was yeah
we have we have a perfect connection we
have uh our gigabit line is it
solidified our i.t guy's here we've
we've we've built up
and put everything's good we have we've
had the green light the whole time but
for some reason the stream has been
dropping off
[Music]
very very because of me it's never
happened before
yeah we've had instances where our
internet flickers
and we can see on our on our system the
the stream rate the bit rate
and so there's been instances where it's
like something was wrong it turned out
there was an electrical surge a
lightning strike and it fried one of our
network
boxes or whatever and so then we were
trying to so then we couldn't even use
our backup internet
we have backup internet so it's an
automatic system when one goes down it
switches over automatically and there's
a bump we can see that happen this time
nothing on our end i'm skeptical as you
are
about uh that it's that anyone that it's
nefarious i think i worked with mines
for so many years that
it's usually 98 of the time a technical
glitch
well i hope i hope it is a technical
because you know otherwise that's even
more
stuff for us to worry about but we have
this
lua coder says tim there are a lot of
chinese communist sympathizers in the
chat today
china actually sends people to american
social media to spread propaganda and
pays them for it
they're called wu maos which means 50
cents is that
yes i got threatened by them to mao uma
is a 50 cent army
so every time when you become internet
troll go to say something
in favor of the you know the communist
party
and attacking you know whoever like me
for example on my page
they get paid 50 cents really yes google
it's 50 it's a mile it's a 50 cents army
i got a threat
on my page don't you want to come home i
once did a video about conflict with
china and what china was doing in the us
potentially going to war and a bunch of
western seeming chinese chinese
youtubers
were like they were they were pro china
youtubers
telling me i was wrong and making
rebuttal videos and coming after me i
just ignore it
i don't care people whatever team they
are paid no influencers
we have to be careful how deeply the ccp
infiltrated into america like my human
rights
and liberty activists in this country
from china somebody who actually was
jailed in china before
they're they're trying to hurt him here
they burn his car
bert like statues the way the way i see
it is
you know we're all we're running towards
this end goal
and you've got people trying to distract
you all the time they're throwing things
at you from the sidelines
i'm not going to stop and get into an
argument with the guy who's
next to the marathon i'm in a marathon
man i gotta play stop the chat you
become an easier target you gotta keep
moving
all right paul bedard says tim nailed it
government and corp
corporate executives love and envy the
ccp model the democratic process is an
inconvenience for them
the will of the people is irrelevant
because they don't respect citizens they
are beneath them
hmm yes scott or
uh ol uh sowski scott dolozowski says
i've been a regular viewer for over a
year now and lily is by far my favorite
guest you've had on thank you for
sharing your story mrs williams
hopefully you can enlighten more
americans
thank you i will i will until i die
jason van kirk's i'm glad i got to watch
this one live i'm sure youtube is going
to take this one down
the stream has been dropping off but we
record them all we put them up on a
variety of platforms so
plus we're gonna have a members only
segment that's gonna be at around 11 p.m
at timecast.com so go check it out
laurel says lily tong williams william's
on fire i love this woman
so much fire from sichuans too much
spicy food
and you were born in the year of the
dragon you told me yes i'm dragon lady
too
my husband always tell me please go
focus on liberty don't
don't [ __ ] with me anymore
i love it what year were you born 79.
what what does that make ian
i don't know it's every 12 years you
have to i should look i'm a tiger it's
the chinese
oh tiger my dad is tiger yeah tiger
what's it called the chinese birth
chin is zodiac chinese my husband is a
a ball a pig so actually according to
chinese zodiac it's very funny
dragon and the pig get along we have you
married for 31 years
i am the goat are you really that is the
greatest of all time
you call me the goat i like that that's
awesome
fran drake uh dredger is that
pronouncing it right drinker
lily do you come to middle schools yes
and sixth to eighth grade if they're
studying world history
the teachers can request me as their
classroom
like guest speaker cool really for
liberty my facebook page
there you go all right let's see
uh my kismo joe was i machismo my kismo
it's time to start the 2a party bridge
the gap between the left and the right
call it the constitutional party 2 uh 2a
lily was great to hear most of your
story something kept trying to interrupt
the video
it's yeah it was cutting out every so
often it was weird and i'm looking at it
like we're our internet's perfect
yeah it's not on our end i can see it
this one's worth a full clear stream
we do have the recording maybe we can
make sure people see that on the website
or something
so you do have the whole thing yeah we
record it it'll be on itunes and spotify
and all that stuff and
i think podcast yeah pandora now dane
shell says
ian nailed it most of the rhetoric is
based on feeling feelings only run one
layer deep if you go deeper you run to
logic
that's right people get that's why our
brain is it's a human being should have
logic and reason
and your your stomach there's a lot of
neurons in your stomach it the food you
eat can really change your mood and the
way you feel
yeah but we are human beings we have all
of that you know we do have emotions and
feelings too
you know that's how we got to you know
calmly talk to each other
respect each other yes here's a good one
fomo says super chat just for having
this amazing woman on
if 20 of quote our side had half of this
woman's enthusiasm there'd be no
struggle god bless you
true thank you that's what i'm saying if
people were were
animated there wouldn't be a question
all right wow you have awesome
supporters
so i can't read uh uh
chinese characters so i can't read this
the chinese character
yeah i can't read the chinese characters
uh from cara face i see your super chat
but i can't read i
don't even know how to pronounce it it
just looks like you know i don't know
where to begin
sorry i have i have a youtube chinese
channel mandarin
what's the channel and it's actually
called a
huay and chinese voice of chinese
americans
so i'm trying to get the chinese to be
um kind of paying attention what's going
on in their new country
and getting involved locally because we
have to focus on
what's going on here now otherwise it's
kind of dangerous we all have no home to
go
because you know if we lose america no
place to go
this is a really great super chat cletus
curtis says i know it's a good guest
when i'm fighting tears while holding my
300 blackout
[Laughter]
i got you know i got a little emotion of
myself and i cannot help it people said
you are so passionate your passion is
contagious
well because you know my memory coming
back to me i i cannot help it
to be passionate you know well i guess
we need more pets in this country right
yes
yeah slenzer says best best
guest yet thanks for finding dave smith
his secretary of state
well that's great that'll be on on dave
and uh you know but uh absolutely
get some more libertarians in the house
he's funny you know
david yeah
yeah uh i i thought the libertarian
party was a joke until
i saw what he was doing and what he was
talking about and he's him and
the mises caucus and you know i think
there's a bunch of good people coming in
and they're they're
reinvigorating it or invigorating in the
first place i guess yeah
someone gary johnson's cool but i mean
like he was really low energy
you know he he was not too bad the first
time running the second time i don't
know what happened
it seemed like he got disillusioned and
thought well it's
there's no i have no chance this this
big i can't stop the big machine i'm
there i'm gonna get one percent this is
nuts so he just he just started acting
like a clown like he just started having
fun
you know that's what it seemed like all
right this is a good one blackrock
beacon says i want this woman to go
berate both congress and senate on
behalf of free people everywhere she is
my spirit animal
tim keep bringing on people who have
survived communism thank you more need
to hear these stories
absolutely yes all right let's see
thank you thank you wow very encouraging
cameron terry says hey tim big fan but
i'd like to ask for a little bit of
elaboration
when it comes to the private mandate of
something like a vaccination what
happens to the concept of your
your rights and where mine begin
especially as variable and important as
meds
so uh i think there's got to be medical
exemptions i have to think that i think
they have to be
um leaning towards lacks in that you
have to give
the the benefit of the doubt to the the
employee not the employer however
it's also based on the size of the
business these are really complicated
things especially
i especially start learning about this
as i'm like building a business
business size matters if a company has
less than 50 employees
i i really do side with the with the
employer on this one in in most
capacities
but i do think we need labor rights for
a lot of you know you you can't have
scams and stealing from paychecks and
things like that employees have to have
rights
in terms of like a vaccine or job
requirement
small businesses i think should have the
discretion to run their businesses for
the most part as they see fit
i think serving a public accommodation
is different i don't think there should
be mandatory vaccines for
for customers employees is different
that that employer does not owe you a
job and you don't owe him
work or anything that's a that's a deal
struck between you both
do you think that if a company were to
create a mandatory vaccine for an
employee that had got that took the job
before
the man to take one of the mandatory
vaccine was initiated that they should
and the person refuses that the
employees should have a payout package
when they're released my personal belief
is yes but i think that would be
but i'm saying personal as in like if i
ran a business that's what i would do
should the government mandate it and
stuff there's a lot of these questions
aren't black and white that's one of the
biggest challenges because people will
say things like
oh if you believe this how do you
believe this and i'm like because
they're two different scenarios and
circumstances and we're dealing with
like a granular
legal system to figure out the best way
to navigate these things
you know if someone the way the way i
feel is like if you're using public
space with public plumbing and public
roads and access to public uh
fire services and police and all that
stuff then
taxpayers should have access to this
building because if you're occupying the
space and refusing to service a certain
type of person
because of some like you know
ideological belief or like you oppose a
certain kind of identity group
well that space could be occupied with
by somebody else i don't i don't see us
having to
accommodate you for if you're not going
to accommodate the public in return
employees are different like a business
choosing to have an arrangement with
with an employee is like there's 10
employees of this business in a given
month there's a hundred thousand
customers walking out the door in a
given month is that scale matters
but i don't think it's perfect i'm not
saying that i i you know i i would say
this
to quote chris rock in the movie dogma i
don't have beliefs necessarily of ideas
beliefs are hard to change ideas you can
change so clearly when michael malus
came on the show and started saying much
stuff i was like actually those are
really good points
and then i probably moved like a little
bit more down the libertarian spectrum
because of that because your alignment
shifted definitely because
you hear smart people give you good
arguments and then you know it's not
just the medical exemption
religious exemption also people who
already were infected have antibodies
there are so many
exemptions but they just don't even talk
about it you cannot even throw that out
there
people who already got kobe tested
positive they're young have antibodies
and is that the more dangerous actually
for them to continue to take
another vaccine on top of their you know
old
antibodies i don't know i'll say this um
people should talk to their doctors
because
uh someone i know actually talked to
their doctor and their doctor said if
you've had covet two recently you can't
get it so you need to talk to a doctor
but
right so you bring back a medical
decision like normally between you
and your family members and doctors at
least government should stay out of it
and these employers should consider all
that kind of exemptions religious is a
big one
and i can already hear all the leftists
laughing and saying the conservatives
who are pro-life i'm not pro-life
you know there's a lot of people who are
pro-life um i've had a lot of moral
arguments but i've always been
private medical decisions have to be
between the the doctor and the
individual and when it comes to pro-life
and pro-choice
that is a hefty moral conundrum no that
i don't have the answers to
so i can only say i'm i can put it this
way i am not one of these conservatives
who have marched around for pro-life
i have always been in more libertarian
that regard so
don't bring those leftist arguments here
it bears no purchase
also no vaccine passport this should be
consistent throughout the world
now eu is doing that it's like a oh
so people cannot even travel to here
you'll spend money there as tourists
anymore
that's like well the sense though if you
make people carry this passport
what else are you gonna make people to
carry on
on their cell phone it's like a little
cold you know
track everything all right my friends we
are going to
have a members only segment coming up
and we're going to talk uh probably
we'll probably we'll we'll probably get
into some things you know youtube
doesn't allow and
this always makes those uh those uh
establishment media types angry that we
can have these conversations over at
timcast.com so become a member
it should be up around 11 pm or so you
can follow us at tim cast irl
you can follow me at tim cast did you
want to lily shout out any social media
or your organization or anything yes if
you want to write to me
and contact me i have a public page lily
for liberty
l-i-l-y number four liberty lady for
liberty sounds very good
and my twitter is also literally for
liberty that's where
you know and i was found by lydia
and my youtube channel is lily tong
williams if you're not
on facebook you can always follow my
youtube
and unsubscribe and share because it's
very educational especially you have
young people
who really want to learn more like some
of my interviews people will write to me
oh lily after you interview actually i
started to really think about
blm i used to really support because
they started here oh
trend marks what does that mean they
start to do research
so it's very encouraging so i will
appreciate you go share my stories and
follow me
and and thank you tim for having me
tonight absolutely thanks for coming
thanks um you can follow me ian
crossland and uh at iancrosson.net if
you want a nexus point for most of my
social media and activity thanks for
coming guys
and i just want to say that i hope that
you guys will join over at our website
to help us stick it in the eye of the
mainstream media because they're not
fans of ours and we're not fans of
theirs
you guys may also follow me on twitter
at sourpatchlids as i document the
training of my little cat dip today i
trained him to sit he's a very good boy
he's very treat responsive and he's
adorable
join me there we'll see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out
bye guys
you